in my opinion before the latin american and
caribbean with tres picos villalongín in
partnership for vaccines and americans
bucks international made in latin
america for latin american world
technology
and
then
the english stuart partners brothels and
yuca bucks
but you know that vaccination helping
this exceeds pandemics la  oliva
telemadrid more is not fit work to
repair better future pandermix bodies and
de camps on twitter after great role are
able to demonstrate before
administrations before sword
of health partnership to belong to day
to be there will create stranger mobile
health systems in latin america
i
[  music]
james
is cool
evans
these supports
investments in health and
vision pharmaceuticals
the
vet universities research
center's interesting
andrew to see
the beach and touring division university
from both sides
in a bowl
health research projects support for
fans
and europe
are soldiers lead their sector
underworld the vaccines ter  apias a
health
house is safe and effective
with
the
control center
[Music]
district 36 absolutely concluded
american partners
inter american development bank team
europe es investing standard knightley
new rules in health project in latin
america and the caribbean
the include may contribution  they are
actors from spanair agency for
international cooperation and
development and all for small world of
warcraft defending financial support
turbay except in tuvo before mexico
enrique ar exploring option effort
port in chile costa rica uruguay in
colombia
king
corporation between the beatles
whitman and sexy stores made  in latin
america and the caribbean do we work of
the year ping
thank you very much for me anyway it
makes me very very excited to be
here today in brussels in the presentation
of this initiative together with
the president of the european commission to
my friend úrsula
una  initiative that we have promoted from
the european commission and also  Even from the
government of Spain from the first
moment only two years ago it seems like
it was a long time ago but
only two years ago Europe began to
emerge from the first and brutal confinement
caused by the cobe 19 pandemic
but it was not only Europe that
suffered the consequences  In 1919, other
regions of the world were
tremendously affected by the
successive waves of this virus that
changed the life of the planet and one of the
hardest-hit regions was precisely
Latin America and the Caribbean, which at various
times came to bear
mortality figures very low.  above its
world weight in population in europe and
consequently in spain' we have been
very aware from the beginning not only of
the inequality gaps that we have
in our continent in our country
but of those existing in different
regions of the world and for that reason our
policy was from the outset to
contribute to universal access to
the vaccine the president  The
commission has said it even before
fully vaccinating our population, both the
European Union and Spain
have committed to donating vaccines
throughout the planet and especially
by Spain in Latin America and the
Caribbean.
Since then our country Spain has
Donated more than 21 million vaccines to
the region, which adds to the
global financial contribution of the 182 million
euros that we have contributed from Spain
against the pandemic. I believe that the
initiative of the Europe team that we are
presenting today in support of the production
of vaccines and the  resilience
of health systems in latin america and
the caribbean expresses expresses the importance
of the lessons learned during
these two years of pandemic the first is
universal access to be heard on
many occasions say to the president
of the commission and I share it a hundred
percent universal access to
safe and effective vaccines that are
better guaranteed by betting on decentralization  tion
of its production and secondly because of
the strength of our
health systems and public health and that this
initiative is launched today is
important for four reasons that I
would like to share with all of you
firstly because it is the expression
that  the european union and its institutions
place latin america and the caribbean
among their main priorities
we europeans are one more piece of a
multipolar world the war in ukraine
shows us that there are some
powerful countries and neighbors of the union that
fight our main values ​​of
tolerance  of political pluralism,
democracy and freedom, for this reason
we believe that it is important to consolidate
ties with the regions that do share
those values ​​that the
European Union also represents and support them in everything
possible on their path to
prosperity and in that sense, dear
Úrsula  I think it is essential
that the global gateway that has been
discussed these days pr  precisely in
brussels on the european days of
development pay special
attention also to latin america'
the second reason is because we do it
with the focus of the europe team at the
helm this new perspective that
the commission has led allows us to align
all the collective efforts of the
European institutions of all the
member states as the best guarantee
of coherence and
consequently maximize the impact this concept of
team your initiative allows us an
absolutely horizontal
transversal approach that takes advantage of all the
synergies and that adds different
heterogeneous projects that advance towards the same
objective as well  In this case, to favor
the production of vaccines and also the
resilience of health systems, we
propose to work initially on three
axes: first, technology transfer
and research, as
the president of the commission has said, and
secondly, the exchange of
experiences at the level  regulated  A
fundamental river and, thirdly, the
mobilization of the private sector towards
investment in this region.
The third reason for the importance of
this initiative that we are presenting today is
that it has been built from its inception on the
basis of dialogue with regional organizations
in the field of  health and
I give this important importance
because the purpose of complementing the
efforts that the region is already making and
responding to the needs that each
of its countries have identified seems to me
essential for
the regional organizations
of Latin America to be effective in our approach  and the
Caribbean have already done a great job
and we recognize that there are projects
underway and very interesting prospects
for the present and the future to
which we want the European Union and
its institutions to join with today's announcement
a new phase begins  in which even
more we will have to jointly outline
development roadmaps between the region
of America  Latin America and the Caribbean and the
European Union and the fourth and last reason that
I would like to share with all of you
is that we incorporate healthcare as a
priority in
Europe and Latin America and the Caribbean and
above all that we want to promote the
transfer and local development of
technology a cutting-
edge vaccine technology focused on mRNA in
adaptable messenger applicable to
present and future needs in the
region and consequently what we
are doing is looking to the
future as we do when betting on the
resilience of health systems
to ensure its strength in the face of
risks such as those we have known and
those that may come in the future, and
we always do so while supporting
economic development,
scientific development, and technology in the region.
In short, we believe that this
initiative that we are undertaking today  launching is
a European awareness of the
needs of Latin America and the
Caribbean one more example  of the will
that the European Union has to open up to
reinvent its way of relating to
Latin America and the Caribbean based
on closeness, proximity and
shared decisions in this regard and
before concluding I want to
especially thank the president for
her leadership  your global vision from the
beginning in this reality I want to
thank you dear Ursula for your interest
in fostering relations between the
European Union
and our partners in the
Latin American and Caribbean region, which is very
important for the European Union, not
only for Spain and its commitment
precisely the commitment of the president of
the commission to work tirelessly
in favor of a better europe and a
better world these initiatives today without a doubt
escape the political and
media news because obviously we
are all thinking of
ukrainian and ukrainian men and women but
let's not forget  that cob still exists and
that there are societies that are still suffering the
onslaught of  cobi and that consequently
we have to continue strengthening the
multilateral order and a
multilateral response that I believe that with this
initiative from the European Union, from
the European Commission and the countries that
are pushing in favor of it,
we are giving yet another proof of regret in the
solidarity response that we have  to give
to a global crisis such as the copper pandemic,
so thank you very much,
President, for your leadership, for your
solidarity, and for the example that you
have always given at the helm of the European Commission.